welcome to comedy kamisato TV we are on
the bus is me and worse Sal Jackson so
trail mark is behind the camera
I didn't want a mr. now
we just left Cracker Barrel Macon
Georgia I've been a cracker before I've
never reviewed it Cracker Barrel is an
underrated establishment it is a staple
on the road I've eaten there lots of
times it's consistent there's nothing
funny about consistency it's just a
solid business I've never walked out of
a Cracker Barrel think about the foot
just I've always felt good when I've
left at Cracker Barrel is the Tim Duncan
of chain restaurants
it's a superstar but slightly forward
but efficient and it's going to get you
20 and 10 when you need it it gives you
where you need to be also a little
keyboard man
since Benny don't want another keyboard
$20 for a keyboard it's late hours so be
able to pursue my dream of being the
time hit maker named Apple order of the
do's named Hannibal I'm gonna make the
most hits that's why I try to put myself
in the smallest category as possible and
that gives me the opportunity to succeed
it's a small category I'm across those
other dudes if there are other dudes I'm
crushing I don't think there's any other
competition but you know you got to make
yourself the best that's what you have
to do that's what a Lil Wayne did and
other rappers ello but they just say I'm
the best rapper alive or restaurantes
say we got the best hot dogs in the
world and nobody's really challenging
them on that you just got to say that
[ __ ] and then people like it must be the
best if they feel that good about it so
I'm the best at the keyboard and back to
Cracker Barrel some people
feel weird about the name the Cracker
Barrel yeah and I could get that but
[ __ ] that man
I just got a country boy breakfast and a
ham eggs hash browns and gravy tonight
even eat and some sliced apples and
grits and [ __ ] was under 10 bowels
consistent this consistent like Lionel
Richie
I don't know if that's a solid analogy
I've been waiting my whole career to
compare Lionel Richie to sub that means
this man sometimes we fail the life
that's okay and we're back that jump cut
is because we say something slanderous
and we won't tell you it is but don't
want to deal with that at home so right
now I'm just trying to get this goddamn
keyboard and make some hits the Gibbs
type of cracker brows consistent they
get all that well you know what this
first time I saw a keyboard there I
don't know if they've ever been they've
been there and they just this is the
first time they placed it really well
but they placed it for my dumb impulse
buy needs it works on me some of the
funds go back in for it could be put it
right here you got damn right I did
shout out to the person who does the
organizing for cracker girl
the norm were an old lady by the time I
walked in you already had it in your
hands I feel like Cracker Barrel a rob a
semi-truck and it'll echo we got full of
keyboards we got a facility boys might
be nice and jelly beans it lambs treat
you are the Dickey Simpkins to Cracker
Barrel
Tim Duncan not go work with you got
their bank